[Music]  here in this video we will showcase all  the dinosaurs and clone species that  will appear in jurassic world dominion  we will show you a size comparison  taking all the species that have been  seen in the prologue the trailer as well  as the ones that are officially  confirmed to appear in the movie not all  of them are dinosaurs some of them are  just related species but there are a  couple of them that appeared before the  giant reptiles did but they also look  very similar to them so let's get to it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so i hope you have enjoyed watching this  video and with that we come to the end  of it so do hit that like button for  support and subscribe as well to be a  part of the minecube family but most of  all smash that bell icon for regular  updates on new videos right here on this  channel till the next one take care fam